leonardo Donatello Michelangelo and
Raphael are back they're here to take
down the Foot Clan who is the Foot Clan
and what is their purpose after watching
this movie I can honestly tell you
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles heroes in a
half shell turtle power when I saw this
trailer I had really high hopes they
were really high like I was stoned when
I saw the first trailer then twenty
percent on rotten tomatoes really got me
depressed like I didn't masturbate for
at least three days so I went to this
movie expecting something really dull
and really stupid and you know what you
get instead well actually you know you
get something pretty stupid I'm not
seeing it's like terrible I mean knowing
me wrong it's a pretty bad movie there's
some good stuff in it too sort of for
starters the writing of this film it's
just a bad script I felt like we watched
a script that was still being written is
this didn't feel like fully fleshed out
and the writing of a lot of these
characters was just it was bad like
megan fox is April O'Neil she's a fox
for these crews
everyone know she's hot and that I would
[ __ ] her okay like if she wanted a
gangbang she wanted me to be one of the
guys I would totally participate and
everyone knows she's she's a shitty
actress and she's by no means like great
in this film and I in its argument was
whether or not she's good for what we've
come to expect from megan fox and when I
say come I don't mean see um she does a
fairly decent job for a megan fox
performance but the writing of this
journalist is just stupid she is without
a doubt got to be one of the dumbest
journalist I've ever seen into that
scene in the trailer where there's like
ninjas getting thrown into the subway
station that [ __ ] it's only in the film
and she's taken hostage and anyone with
a basic concept of common sense would
know not to whip out your cell phone and
start recording what's going on in such
a non discreet way especially when a bad
guy with a gun pointed at you is walking
towards you but no she's like I'm still
gonna keep on recording and then this
this is probably the dumbest moment to
me out of the whole movie this is the
defining moment where you're like this
character is [ __ ] she's a boss
played by whoopi goldberg it was so
necessary for this film I couldn't have
imagined anyone else playing the role
but she's black and I like black girls
early on in the film april O'Neil takes
a photo a photo on her phone of the four
turtles it saved to her [ __ ] phone
and then when she's presenting evidence
to Whoopi that these vigilantes taking
on the Foot Clan or Turtles she uses
just the right evidence to make her look
stupid like it's like what the real
Megan Fox would present and the one
thing she doesn't show them is a goddamn
photo she took the night before of them
flipping over buildings now those are
just two examples of stupidity trust me
there's there's a lot more in this phone
now I want to mention this guy cuz I was
surprised that I really enjoyed it
meaning i always enjoy him but you know
instead of playing a douchebag you
played a really nice guy will arnett
he's a cameraman who's like in love with
April O'Neil by the way no I do just
don't see cameraman at all on this guy
but he's still enjoyable to watch he's
the only human on screen that was fun
and not so dumb one of my biggest issues
with this film is the villains first you
got William fig nurse character he's the
main bill
here's the issue they have that moment
where he reveals his master plan of why
he's a bad guy and when you hear his
motivation it is without a doubt one of
the dumbest motivations I have ever
heard written for a villain but it's
it's so unimaginative and honestly won't
spoil anything for you if I tell you
he's basically a rich ass [ __ ]
who wants to be in his own words stupid
rich that's it he's already one of the
most powerful people in New York very
wealthy very much respected but he wants
a little more money and he you know he's
obviously working with the Foot Clan and
I've said many minutes wondering why did
the Foot Clan do anything of what they
do like I don't get the motivation they
don't truly explain it or justify it at
all they're [ __ ] that's basically
what they do they behave like [ __ ]
they're just a bunch of ninja dicks with
assault rifles and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles I really did not like the fact
that they made shredder a secondary
villain it's all admit at times shredder
was pretty [ __ ] scary in this movie
like whenever he comes charging at the
turtles it's like a little [ __ ] how are
they gonna take down this guy you ask
yourself and the light how they made
shredder like a skilled martial artist
who gets like equipped with this
high-tech samurai suit because he served
was like 500 pounds and they're like six
feet tall so you need to create a
villain that can you know equally stand
against them or be isn't even more
imposing opposing I mean nice ignore the
definition of any of those words and
secondly if they're gonna reboot teenage
mutant ninja turtles don't make the
legendary villain the secondary villain
to a bad guy that you really don't find
that scary to a bad guy no one [ __ ]
know shredder was always just ten times
more menacing off of appearance than
William Fichtner ever was like don't get
it wrong will your figure is losing damn
good actor but as far as shredder goes
would have rather seen him way more than
some like greedy little [ __ ] like this
film it's just filled with so many
problems it actually makes it rather
enjoyable like it's not so bad that's
good but there are plenty of moments
weren't so bad and so unintentionally
bad that it's kind of funny
this is character that's not really
featured in the trailers the legendary
splinter the sensei the father of the
turtles he's cool he does some badass
[ __ ] especially with that tail imagine
what that could do to a lady mm-hmm he
put the tail in the vagina people were
initially grossed out when they saw the
turtles in the trailers I honestly
didn't give a [ __ ] they're supposed to
be mutated Ninja Turtles so the fact
that they look like that I was okay with
and the same philosophy applies for
splinter blom it splinter he looked
creepy as hell he's a good character
total badass but you'd swear he do some
like weird shits your genitalia I don't
know why but honest to god I got that
weird tingling my balls and penis as if
like a pedophile was about to touch me
like there's nothing in this film that
comes remotely close to employing that
splinter will molest someone but I just
might my balls reacted that way for some
reason now why am i saving this next
topic for last because they're the best
part of this entire movie and I guess at
the end of the day that's what mainly
counts the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
okay so these guys look pretty [ __ ]
awesome they're the saving grace of this
movie now for someone who is like a big
fan of the turtles growing up I was
really let down by the fact that they
did not explore enough character in this
film with the Turtles now some might
argue it's about turtles can you really
give that much depth to them laughter a
you know successful comic book series an
awesome cartoon show 3 pretty damn good
live-action films yeah I think it's safe
to say you could add more depth to them
but for the most part even though they
are two-dimensional characters they
still were the most fun to watch they
still made this film enjoyable and
honestly like the first hour it's like
april o'neil story and i wish they'd
just put like ninety percent of the
focus on the turtles then some like
boarding batter it in humans yes they do
have distinct personalities there's
Leonardo the leader Raphael to James
Dean Donatello has like Benedict
Cumberbatch's Sherlock dorky version and
Michelangelo who I really relate to a
lot I have a feeling he'd like a lot of
my dick jokes but playing that was it
they were their labels but not much more
to it they could have done so much more
with their personalities but whoever
those actors are they did it
really good job and a great chemistry
you know for something that doesn't have
a lot of material written in depth for
them they managed to still bring them a
life they're all really funny and they
really do kick some serious too lass
like they're pretty badass that one
fight scene where it takes place in the
snow like pans down that's one of the
best action sequences I've seen all year
but like thank you nothing to establish
why leonardo was the leader Rafael's
always like quit ordering me around why
are you acting like the leader and
instead of feeling like hey Raph cool
your [ __ ] I was like I have to view a
ref I I don't quite get why he's the
leader because there's not one [ __ ]
moment that establishes at all how he
became the leader other than the fact
that he wants to lead I'm a bio he's
always the badass you can explore and
they don't explore the badassery but
he's an emotionally complex character
like so much potential and they didn't
meet up to it at all so yes will you
have fun I say yeah most likely because
the turtles are still fun at the end of
the day but it's for the rest of the
movie it's it's pretty bad let me get
straight to the point here oh and all I
gotta say Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
got it disappointingly losing my would
wrong
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me which
turtle are you if you don't like that
mode you to make bucks Martha out there
you can follow all our social networks
for hooked up with all that [ __ ] because
we're [ __ ] youtubers man we got
social media that crap got promote that
[ __ ] we gonna get followers on Facebook
[ __ ] last one at least he won't get
updated every time one of my reviews or
videos are out going to click on this
but about my dick to subscribe that's
right the dick let me tell you something
about this little ninja every time he
wants to mutate out of his turtle shell
and expand he goes Cowabunga on a lady's
vagina and he mainly did that as a
teenager see use the whole title